foreign
[Music]
good afternoon San Francisco
my name is Gregory and I'm coming from
Belgium and I hope in the next coming 30
minutes really to focus on the part on
the topic of the power of the customer I
thank you all as Future Leaders I'm sure
that for many months and many years you
are ready or try to get as close as
possible to your customers by
co-creating product and services to make
sure that you're getting close or very
close to their personal Ambitions but
also keep far away from what they do not
like
now before I continue
like I said I'm Gregory for Linden and
I'm part as of cognizant and I'm proud
to be part of cognizant coherizon has a
big Heritage of always being very
leading in being an early adopter around
technology and also doing Innovation on
the edge
I'm also extremely proud that we are a
very Multicultural environment and last
week I think some magic happened is that
our Indian colleagues succeeded in
landing on the moon
and the moon land that is called
Brian
and this is in sankris Sanskrit the word
means wisdom
and if you scale it down and you go to
Gyan this is all is about knowledge well
I hope in the next coming 30 minutes to
show you that generative AI bring us an
extensive part of new knowledge
which I hope that we all will be applied
to create more wisdom in our own lives
but let's now go
okay
customer experience or the segment of
one or hyper personalization of how we
call it let's be honest happy customers
always buy more
secondly I think we are all conscious
that if you look to customer experience
we've been throwing like hell money to
it but we miserly failed and we will
need to reset and restart the way of how
we deliver customer experience
thirdly a lot of research has proven
that even your customers are willing to
pay a higher price if the products or
the services that you're delivered are
sustainable
and fourthly if I look to my son he only
start doing Financial or banking actions
at eight o'clock in the evening and
hardly do anything overnight
so in the context of a segment of one I
think we will read to reimagine every
aspect and I see three core categories
the first category is the focus on the
persona for many years in the context of
hyper personalization we have tried to
understand the individual I've learned
that this is not good enough
we also need to understand the community
around the individual when I was talking
with our marketing lady last week she
had dinner with her friends and since
today she is buying Echo paper I need to
know that
the second topic is the marketplace the
marketplace is where we connect the
customer with our Enterprise
and they will see there many companies
are trying to apply the kind of Amazon
model next to their core products and
services they are selling more and other
things and they're also leveraging the
ecosystem
and then thirdly our core if I want to
be digital in the front end and I want
to get into a real-time dimension
but if my God is not modernized then
still there's a lot of a lot of manual
handshakes happening there I will never
be able to deliver on that promise
and there you already see with Janet API
we have a massive opportunity I will
talk mostly about our generative
customer experience Navigator which I
think is focused on the personas but on
the marketplace also there the concept
of indeed degenerative knowledge
Navigators where we indeed are able to
Fast Track information Discovery we are
able to create much more advancable
insights and augment our decisions is a
quite powerful means and then if we talk
about the core yeah the core I think
we want to optimize processes yeah but
also do not forget in the car and we
have been in one of our thought
leadership papers around the future of
us data management is one of the most
underestimated jobs that we need to do
guess what generative AI can help us to
complete this journey
how does it all connect together
well like I said the power of the
customer is increasing much more
and I think I will prove even that it's
getting into a kind of insane state
but we need to accept that this is part
of the reality a lot of the
organizations are trying to create kind
of new Revenue models yeah to their core
Services look in the financial world I
have some Financial customers that
really are creating a kind of
marketplace to create also type of new
Revenue models yeah equally also indeed
I would say to have an all-around
Services perspective we still need to
optimize control but I think I see that
a lot of Enterprises really want to
become their best friends of their
customers they want to keep their
customers on track they want to become
their life coach their personal advisor
and to be able to succeed in doing that
there is one essential part we cannot
broadcast any more information to them
we need to get into an active dialogue
and I'm proud that I can mention this
yeah
because I think part of creating that
emotional connection for a lot of you
all in this audience I think the
implementation of conversation AI was
already a big step
and I'm very proud that we are allowed
to mention it in the fact that we are a
partner of ING Bank who has a Clear
Vision around the human Channel Vision
strategy were indeed the core entry
point is their mobile banking app
but they have succeeded with the
implementation of conversational AI to
deflect much more to chat
at the same time to receive and took out
to a higher level of customer
satisfaction but equally also true yeah
when they see it's becoming indeed
difficult
still they got the human touch of the
video call that starts up where the
customer gets human advice
and again this is a nice example of an
extremely first good step in the context
of creating that emotional connection
but guess what
conversation AI is good but the context
of intense and intense creation is still
a word it's still a burden
could we do something about that
so let's now start about
genitive AI
and I think it all started a little bit
in for every and I think we were honored
to be able to participate and
collaborate with with our customers but
also leverage the better products of of
Google
and I think I've learned two things
first of all you do not know more than
me so I think we all need to cook to
co-create and collaborate every day
because the world is so moving fast that
the reality is in the combination of the
knowledge of both of us what today is
possible or not possible tomorrow is
possible so we need to continuously
track and follow every day what is
happening but then the good enough
statement first is the perfect tailors
perfect job I've learned that there are
three types of weighing of how to
leverage foundational models or apply
generative AI you can apply it out of
the box based on API calls but you also
can take a tailored Channel tvi approach
which I will show we have done and we
have taken that as an opportunity and
then the third one I think I don't know
if you saw it as cognizant but we're
also quite committed to make sure that
certain large language models are
getting into a certain domain a certain
function of value where we help to
create to complete the chords next of
the large language models
but here is the magic that I think is
creating all the excitement in the
context of the impact on the customer
Journey
multi-channel multi-language multi-role
the CEO can talk with an agent
somebody sitting in Manila can talk
French with somebody sitting in Belgium
and also I think in the month your
channel perspective I can build a
history and a memory that there is no
reset anymore of the communication with
my customers
so I'm getting by default to an extreme
Rich dialogue
by the way I do this also by leveraging
my own information because I want to
differentiate and you see there on the
right side yeah
it can create a substantial cost
decrease which we all like within the
Enterprise but I think what is far more
important
it also create bigger motivation within
our organization
we have now customer services agents
with bigger type of motivation yeah and
let's be honest what's the best source
for customer satisfaction is having
happy employees by because by default
they will deliver a service which I
think is is better
I'm always saying instead of lip
Services we made our hands dirty
and we proved whatever we have
envisioned together with our customers
brought it into reality and we defined
three personas first of all using
genitive AI in direct interaction with
the customer
second is call it the call agents or the
financial advisors or the advisors
within the company to to make use for
genitive AI as a product productivity to
to enrich the dialogues and the third
Persona was before even a customer gets
into a human communication that we are
pre-prepped
to immediately kick off the right
communication and we do this by
leveraging and using information coming
out of our conversational AI systems
out of our call center systems out of
our CRM databases out of our product
databases so I think we have been
leveraging this big time I'm always
saying I've been honored
to work together with my teams with
different financial institutions
different telcos and different media
companies and I think that is where we
have created the excitement in what we
have and what we will shown around our
tailored tailored info about that we
have created because what were the
design of the customer experiences
principles
first of all we needed to make sure that
we create the right questions and
answers there needs to be a reasoning a
history and memory
we tried the calculation and certainly
the personalization
let's start
the soccer dilemma
the left side
is the customer services that I should
have Kelton but guess what what happened
it was Friday noon
my setup box from my television field it
was broken
okay I'm renting the device so I went to
the services Job Shop and they gave me
another set of books I come at home
the auto install fields
what do I do I pick up the phone and I
call the customer service and they say
Mr for Linden
bad luck it's four o'clock our back
office is already starting the weekend
we will not be able to do anything and
so you will need to wait until Monday
before we can look about how to fix the
perspective and I'm saying guys but
it's weekend do I now need to tell my
family no television this weekend
I will be the bad messenger they will
kill me
yeah Mr Linden sorry but we cannot do
anything
so
as being a responsible dad I go to the
family and say no television this
weekend
and guess what my daughter said Daddy no
problem
you have an iPad
we have an app a television app on the
iPad from the same Telco company
we have a smart TV
I launched the TV on my app I do a swipe
and we look television and say oh my God
well I think what we have proven here
this was really awesome by scraping some
of the forums of discussions where all
the Telco discussions are happening we
brought the information into play
and look what happened there imagine
that the customer services agent that
was serving me had that information
available
he or she would have said to me Mr
Belinda you have a problem but the
meanwhile maybe do you have an iPod do
you have a second television yeah that
is indeed the art of the possible so I'm
saying I'm now overnight as a consumer
able to create a better customer service
than the Enterprise itself
this this is completely I call it insane
so the power of the customer is becoming
enormous so we need to step up and make
sure that we make big step in the
delivery of our customer service at the
same time as human beings we are limited
the call center agent is limited in the
knowledge well guess what if you bring
such a productivity tools to them
they can deliver an awesome service and
I'm sure that the call center agent if
he's able or she is able to tell that
story
they also will have a personal level of
satisfaction which I think is is higher
the power of common knowledge again
we see he so he
now what is I think very important also
is that
we know who Sufi is
so free as a customer of us
and she has a mobile subscription no
landline no televisions description we
also know that she is a bad player
so I think Sophie is now asking in
whatever language that she wants
she can ask it in French she can ask it
in English in Flemish it does not matter
anymore for us yeah
but to also look to the answer that we
have been giving to her
we know her situation
so to offer a bundle
would have not created a convenience so
we have said okay
you want to have television we can
give you a single service and activate
it overnight instead of of bringing a
bundle to her two things we have learned
out of that first of all the convenience
factor if I would have proposed a bundle
to Sophie
knowing that she already has it
financially difficult
this would create a bad feeling from her
side
at the same time yeah in genitive Ai and
this is the challenge around leakage I
cannot share them the fact that I know
that she maybe has been hard in paying
her bills so I need to make damn sure
that when I answered the question I do
not expose the fact that I know this
perfect
and then lastly what I want to mention
here
we want to Leverage
on private information
and always making the Allen the G is
that everybody said the move to Cloud
will save a lot of money and a lot of
you ended up paying even more money
I think also here and I think I'm still
do not know the answer but we still need
also the fact of if we bring information
into play
it's tokenized and there is a financial
model behind that that's also something
that we need to create we can create a
better world yeah but it needs to be a
better word to also at a fair price
okay
and this is the big excitement
I have two excitements to tell today but
this is big and every customer
they were flabbergasted when they saw
this
if I create an answer it's not just good
enough to just to create an answer
if I need to tell my daughter about how
to
drag a banking statement out of a
banking app if I give her five keywords
it's enough
because she knows she's digital
she knows how to do it if I call my
father of 80 years old
if I give him five words I'm getting
nowhere I need to be very very
descriptive so look to Victor he's 75
years old I need to be very very
descriptive to Victor in the steps that
he needs to take into account so imagine
yeah your call agents knowing that
Victory is 75 years old
you give him the perfect guidance to
tell a story and give an answer which I
think Victor will like
imagine that you need to ask Victor also
to install an app on his iPad yeah so I
think for me I think this this this I
think this is an excitement where I
think if we are in customer service
everybody wants wants to bring this into
the kind of reality
the magic of prompt engineering
I will come on back but prompt
engineering if I talk about tailored
gen AI then prompt engineering is your
masterpiece
and look here to Peter
Peter thinks that he
will be able to fool us he will test the
system and we actually went to a Telco
one to show this because Peter says I've
seen that if I would buy now a new
subscription I would get a discount of
25 percent
what happened if I now just
cancel my subscription and I subscribe
under the name of my wife
as you're part of the same family it's
not allowed
so you see the answer that has been
created is the fact that Victor could
try but
will not fly
I think what is also important here
is what we call the tone of voice
in an Enterprise context I'm sure that
all of your Enterprises have defined the
way of how to communicate to your
customers a kind of communication style
so you do not only need to have an a
good answer you also need to make sure
that it's applied in the context of your
communication style and I think the art
of prompt engineering is there again
making the big difference
and if you want to take one picture
today
I think that's my golden slide
and prompt Engineering in the context of
generative AI is something that we all
need to master
it's not an engineering piece
it's an art
and look here
it's like you get access to the universe
you have the access to a knowledge which
is as big as the universe if I want to
create Embrace or some value out of it I
will need to start peeling the onion to
get to a pointed very quality answer
and that's what we do with the art of
prompt engineering we are working
together very closely with Google on
this and still let's be honest it's an
every week still discussion topic about
how we fine-tune the role around prompt
engineering and look here
we are that defines our belonging
or reacting in the financial world or
reacting in the domain world in the
retail world
I think that is what we Define
we're also a character and a name which
job role do we have do I remember Forum
operator I'm a call agent I'm a CEO of a
company and I have a name
then you define the mission
the the mission defines a little bit the
behavior
because I can ask a question and kind of
give an immediately a response
but I also can say no no don't give
immediately a response ask a few extra
questions to fine-tune and to get more
knowledge about the situation to be
their pointed because let's be honest
prompt engineering you want to do two
things I think which I think I'm sure
has been one of your main concerns
leakage leakage prevention and
hallucination prevention
and let's be honest I think
we need to make sure that we
know a lot of information we bring a lot
of information into play to create that
perfect answer but we cannot just be
transparent in everything that we play
back maybe there is a Privacy Rule that
we are not allowed to share back for
instance the amount of money that he or
she earns at the moment yeah or I think
we had a nice example if you're 70 years
old and you go to a bank you don't get a
loan anymore that's so many the product
description I cannot just say bluntly to
a 70 or old guy that is asking for a
loan guess what you will not get it yeah
you potentially will defer it to a
Tunisia the history aspect is also a
very nice one
yeah like I said in the in the
multi-channel approach what is the
biggest frustration is the reset of the
discussion
and I think here also in context of our
Taylor Janam tvi approach we've built in
we have a history a history of all the
sessions and we know our customer we
know our customer and we're always
building back on what we have learned
out of the of the time
then defining the context
you know that bringing that information
into play yeah we're taking that an
abstract of the text blocks that we will
use that we finally then indeed will
classify as truths which we called
embeddings which I think is a very
important perspective
and defining that context is also very
key in the context of saying
don't assume anything
if you cannot create the answer because
it's not part of the knowledge
perspective don't try to be creative
make sure that you hand over to a human
agent perspective and then lastly I
think in detail the personalization
approach which I have said
we use the pound too
the Bison version I like the picture
yeah and we also have learned here
something around Levy it's again a very
nice example of reasoning can I ask can
I borrow money
he's a customer yeah we confirm he can
he can borrow some money from us
can I land 10K no problem I can learn
10K
can I land 5K
if I can land 10K I can have 5K but try
to do that with the traditional chatbot
you will not get this answer so again
the reasoning is there but I think what
is more important here is also we
challenged
we challenged a large language model to
do calculations we uploaded a PDF with
formulas in it yeah and we challenged to
do calculations
bat ID
and that's also the reason why as
cognizante we have what we call our AI
cognitive framework because there's some
things that an L M can do but in the
context of our use case and use case
delivery you see we will always make a
combination of still AI narrow AI
together with genitive AI and if you
want to know more we as cognizant have
even built a kind of neural model
orchestrator where we bring together
that Ai and narrow geniei and narrow AI
well together if I run a kyc process I
need to make damn sure that the outcomes
are right because if they are not right
I can I can get indeed a find
so again
put it in a context yeah and use it for
the context that it is there
the last big excitement is this one and
the left
the left is there just for
to be able to understand the dialogue
it's really about what is in the middle
and on the right
and what you see there we have our dear
friend Levy who's speaking Flemish who
is asking a question
and you see
on the right side that Noor who is
sitting in Manila
is having a simultane is having us
orchestrating the dialogue with him
and you see what's happening
Levy is asking a question
is translated into her local language
genitive AI is immediately proposing to
her what a potential good answer would
be that she could give to him and she
needs only to confirm it's translated
and it's going back into into a
into Flemish
did you get it language is not a
constraint anymore
how much of our customer services
department have we tried to Off Track
and offload to lower price countries and
trying to reduce our costs but on the
back of what delivering a worser
customer service well here you see now
language is not a barrier anymore and I
think yeah you also get nor who is much
more happy to create a quality answer
back so she's more motivated in doing
that and you see on the other side of
the world I'm sure that Levy is also
getting extremely happy with the answer
that he is he's getting
okay
our lessons learned around Genet API
that we have applied Within These
Financial customers and also within the
Telco customers
I would summarize as three main
important things
the first thing is about finding the use
case
do not underestimate this
because generative Fai has a multi-task
Dimension and can play in your process
not one role but maybe thousand rolls in
trying to identify what the art of the
opportunity is within the use case with
the applying genitive AI I think it's a
masterpiece that's also the reason why
you see that to be able to achieve this
we also bring in many different roles
into play to be able to do that this
needs to incorporate not only
engineering but also a very advanced
level of design thinking
the second part is then we start doing
something with it and we call it a
cohita framework yeah like I said
you want to create the best answer it's
bad for calculations you want to still
make a combination between traditional
Ai and channel tvi in creating the best
response and the best answer to that and
that the art of prompt engineering is
your Masterpiece it's your Marcus master
orchestrator
but then we need to bring it into
production
and the responsible AI equation I think
it was also this morning mentioned
multiple times
we cannot export this towards the future
I'm an old guy
I'm 25 years in the industry and I
started 25 years ago discussions about
master data management
I have customers that now start spending
money on it
that's the same also with envelopes yeah
I think we have been talking about it
for many years surrounded how many have
acted implemented in a serious way we
cannot export it anymore if we want to
be serious with challenge DVI we will
need to do it in a responsible way in an
Enterprise world and so we need to
professionalize the way of working
and you see that also whatever is in
your use case in the context of your
prompt engineering on a responsible AI
it's always a combination of three
things
you need Ai and engineering but you also
need a lot of strategy and design
elements and do not forget compliance
and regulation is also key and I'm
coming from Europe
we have again the Masterpiece of the
European AI act so by default There Is
No Escape anymore around the legal the
the legal stuff that we need to do but
at the same time in your use case
identification
you will need to ask the question if I
use a large language model if that model
is in line with my ethical standards
within my company I don't know how many
of you have defined ethical standards
within your company
but you will need to make them available
and even test your two test use case
against against this
last if I read the Press I'm always
thinking and listening about Doom
thinking the world is going busted
we are again killing all jobs with
janitive AI no
yeah we are impacting Big Time knowledge
workers
but do not forget what we just talked
about is the fact that first of all to
be able to do something successful with
generative AI we will more than ever
need a soccer team because the
collaboration will be key our user
research experience design people
front-end developers and prompt
Engineers will need to work and group
together as one team but there are also
many new jobs that will be created I
call it the ethical sourcing manager the
buy specialist the AI product manager
the data Detective
so okay we all will save a lot of time
in our work in the context of doing
analyzes and research we will get more
quality back or more quality time back
but equally also we'll see there are a
lot of roles and you see here also a
little bit of a view about the way of
how we think in a kind of four layered
approach about applying genetic VI you
have your interaction layer you have
your genitive AI layer you have your
computation layer yeah
and I think we learned out of the past
if we Implement AI
it was not because we have developed the
psdi that it was used by somebody they
need to trust it but they also needs to
be make sure that it works in a kind of
performance and a good way and then
lastly but at least yeah
playing and using our own private
information and bringing that in play I
think is key
to complete without conclusion I'm
always saying
who doesn't want to have second brain
I think we all do yeah
my wife is telling me that she is my
second brain yeah
but so I think yeah I think we get now
an extension to our brain and I want to
repeat also I think one of our famous
statements of our CEO
I think we're all constrained in our
intellectual capacity
with generative AI that intellectual
capacity that becomes available has
extended
so we will get much more time
to focus on Innovation and value
creation and I think that's the magic
opportunity I think I believe for all of
us
but I think for me the four key verses
do not forget there's a lot of
excitement in the market
but we still will need to apply it into
an Enterprise context
and that's a little bit more complex
we need to do it in a responsible way
collaboration will be key and I think
prompt engineering will be more than
ever yeah leading in in in in in in that
perspective
and I want to thank you also for being
here but I also want to thank my heroes
yeah and these are my heroes
they have been able to make the art of
the possible possible
and look to Rigo I never forgot the day
that he came into my office and say
Gregory it is a beast yeah and it was
the art of saying how can I now manage
the Beast and I think with the art of
brunt engineering we succeeded in
managing the beast but let's be honest I
think there's still a lot to learn and
there is certainly a lot of still yeah
collaborate together with you in making
this kind of game-changing Step a
reality within our Enterprises thank you
thank you